Hi I’m Andrew Heaton
'Fake News'
and this is Mostly Weekly
'Dishonest Media'
Today, we’re talking about....
Fake News-
Fake News.
I just wanted to fit in.
But first, I want to speak to you, dear viewer.
Now, I don’t know much about you.
I don’t know whether you’re watching me
from your home toilet
or someone else’s toilet.
I do know you have excellent taste in webseries.
But without knowing whether you supporting President
Trump or President Winfrey,
I think I can convince you that Donald Trump
creates fake news.
Now Trump claims to be the arbiter of fake
news.
He says he coined the term and he very presidentially
handed out Fake News awards last month.
This is a major honor, the winner is....
The Failing New York Times”
'This is the first win and 15th nomination
for The Failing New York Times.'
It’s really just an honor to be nominated.
But Trump is not the arbiter of fake news,
Trump is the Typhoid Mary of Fake News.
He’s the progenitor.
He’s like a conspiracy theory manifesto
written by a ghost writer
who plagiarized a magician who reveals it
was all an evil twin’s dream within the matrix...
OR AM I ?!?!
So how does Trump create Fake News?
Two ways.
One he makes his detractors so crazy
they forget their journalistic integrity.
In their race to pillory him, they bungle,
cherry-pick, or even make up facts
to confirm their hatred.
And Number two: he flat out lies.
Most recently:
And most of those are from this month!
Now to be fair, I understand the pressure
Trump is under to lie.
I feel it every time I talk to my 7 million
viewers about my jacked deltoids.
I get it!
But Trump goes above and beyond any normal
amount of lying:
“It was the biggest electoral win since
Ronald Reagan.”
No
“We’ve signed more bills than any president
ever.”
Nope.
"My father gave me a small loan of a million
dollars."
Also nope.
I was just endorsed by ICE”
Nuh-uh.
“I don’t know Putin.”
Nope.
“Some of the media is terrific,
but most of it 70 to 75% is absolute dishonest, absolute scum.”
According that same study, “86.2% of reporters
are very sad losers with the worst ratings.”
Yet, there is some truth to media suckage.
Sometimes the media sometimes stoops to Trump’s
level and makes a bunch of unforced errors.
Here’s a list of several facts the media
got wrong about Trump.
This isn’t Diet Coke!
And those are just the errors from major news
outlets.
This misinformation is then disseminated by
your well-meaning but hysterical
Trump-hating friends on social media.
Its part of a phenomenon called “Trump
Derangement Syndrome” or TDS.
Now, unfortunately, TDS is a term coined by
the alt-right,
but hey, even a racist clock is alt-right
twice a day.
"You filthy fascist scumbag liberals allied
with radical Islam!
You people are filth and you know it."
Trump Derangement Syndrome
is when people are so blinded by their rage
against Trump
that they don’t check their facts and reflexively
oppose anything he likes.
Do you suffer from TDS?
Symptoms may include: aneurysms, sore throat,
hair removal, myopia, pussy hat rash,
Twitter frenzy, Hitler comparisonitis, chronic
over-posting, jump cuts,
jump cuts, hyperbole, hyperventilation, hysteria,
hyper-bole-vent-isteria.
TDS is caused by: alarmism, cherry-picking
data, confirmation bias, asshole-reflux,
inflated opinion, clickbait fatigue, or a
rush to publish.
If you suffer from TDS, ask your doctor to
tell you to stop it.
Just stop it, Jesus!
The worst part is, no one needs to suffer
from TDS!
Because there’s no need to exaggerate!
Trump already says and does terrible, stupid things.
It’s like spreading a rumor that the Gymnastics
molester also hates black history month!
He’s already a bad guy.
We don't need to make stuff up!
But the difference between Trump and the media
is that Trump lies all the time
and we’ve come to expect it.
Trump’s lies are obvious and self-serving.
Here’s an analogy:
What makes you think I ate it?
But the media’s misreporting is more subtle.
And when the media slacks off, it bolsters
Trump’s accusations of fake news,
which confirms his supporters’ suspicions
of media bias,
and emboldens him to keep citing “alternative”
facts.
Which in turn enrages the media.
Which in turn enrages Trump.
So it’s a feedback loop.
Within a repetitive cycle, circulating within
a self-propagating continuous system.
Or am I?!?!
The way out of that cycle is for the media
to not slack off.
And since that probably isn’t gonna happen
anytime soon, readers should always be skeptical.
As Supreme Court Justice Abraham Lincoln once
said,
“Don’t believe everything you see on the internet.”
Ehh, we’ll fix that in post.